[Musica]
buongiorno buongiorno io sono del m così
si scrive il mio nome in italiano
così invece si scrive in francese come
lo scrivevo quando vivevo in tunisia ma
se volete sapere come si legge
perfettamente dovrete leggerlo così in
arabo wiz del m bene io ho vissuto con
queste tre identità per tutta la mia
vita è come il mio nome
anch'io vent'anni fa arrivando in italia
ho dovuto cambiare tanto
ho cambiato il modo di mangiare ho
cambiato la lingua che uso tutti i
giorni ho cambiato anche la mia
mentalità
però il più grande cambiamento che è
avvenuto nella mia vita è successo
quando nel 2011
nel mio paese di origine in tunisia è
avvenuta la rivoluzione il popolo si era
messo contro la dittatura
il primo paese arabo a chiedere la
libertà e la democrazia
e io che ero cresciuta in quel paese per
21 anni sotto la dittatura finalmente
finalmente questa rivoluzione avvenuta
dall'altra parte del mediterraneo mi
regalava il più grande regalo la fine
della censura la fine dell'autocensura
potevo dire quello che pensavo ma
soprattutto la libertà di essere una
vera cittadina una donna libera che
viene da un paese libero e vive in un
altro paese libero
ed ecco che la tunisia mi chiamo non
solo io
tanti altri come me di tunisini che
vivono all'estero
ci siamo trovati sulle reti sociali per
discutere insieme ai tunisini in tunisia
insieme alle nostre famiglie alle nostre
comunità per capire come fare per
aiutare per la prima volta perché
eravamo liberi di pensare di pensare noi
stessi ma soprattutto perché siamo stati
finalmente chiamati alla nostra
responsabilità di cittadini cioè quella
di portare ricchezza conoscenza valore
aggiunto al nostro paese io sono tornata
a lavorare in tunisia
rimanendo ancora qua in italia dopo
vent'anni di lavoro nel mondo
dell'informatica
mi sono rimessa in gioco mi sono ri
seduta sui banchi della scuola
ho studiato cooperazione internazionale
adesso sto facendo un nuovo dottorato un
dottorato in strategia urbanistica con
l'idea di portare un pò dall italia
quello che ho imparato quello che è
stato questo grande regalo che mi ha
offerto il mio nuovo paese l'italia alla
tunisia che sonia oggi la democrazia e
sonia la crescita però un certo punto
eravamo lì ti ci chiedevamo ma come si
può per agire per cambiare le cose
dopo 60 anni di dittatura cosa significa
portare ricchezza in questo paese
portarla dall'estero però insieme alle
persone lì come fare sviluppo quando da
sessant'anni le politiche di sviluppo
che sono state promosse sono state
promosse mettendo insieme potenze e
dittatori non hanno risolto i problemi
di povertà non hanno risolto problemi di
malasanità non hanno accorciato quelle
disuguaglianze tra pelle persone non
sono riuscite a contrastare quella
sofferenza delle persone e lo
sfruttamento delle ricchezze sotterranee
nell'africa dalla quale io provengo
ecco come fare sviluppo oggi noi che
siamo semplici individui che vivono
fuori ci siamo messi in rete
abbiamo iniziato a lavorare insieme
abbiamo pensato al concetto di società
civile un concetto che ho scoperto qua
in italia l'idea di appartenere a un
terzo settore e abbiamo fondato
un'associazione io appartengo
un'associazione che ha creato due
filiali una in italia e una gemella in
tunisia e da lì è partita non una nuova
avventura insieme ad altri come me che
dagli stati uniti dal canada dall europa
dal nord africa dal medio oriente ma
anche da hong kong la diaspora tunisina
si è mossa grazie al movimento della
democrazia per poter aiutare e cosa
abbiamo iniziato a fare
abbiamo semplicemente iniziato a mediare
tra chi qui vuole veramente aiutare giu
tra chi qui vuole veramente sviluppare
giu e non solo sfruttare e mediare per
portare soluzioni utili
lavoriamo nel mondo della sanità
pubblica per esempio è la nostra
associazione ha deciso di intraprendere
una strada particolare quella di
accompagnare la riforma delle
istituzioni cioè noi lavoriamo con i
ministeri in tunisia
io parto spesso a lavorare giu ma
lavoriamo anche grazie alle nuove
tecnologie a distanza non si ha più
bisogno di viaggiare continuamente si
possono fare riunioni si possono creare
discussioni a distanza questo
cambiamento noi lo stiamo sfruttando per
portare voci nuove e diverse ma
soprattutto per poter dire che se si
vuole accompagnare la democrazia per la
prima volta in un paese africano
vuol dire che tutti noi dobbiamo
lavorare e questi noi siamo finalmente
in rete il migrante non è un peso
eppure visto così sia dal paese dal
quale lui parte che non lo trattiene con
non li chiede di rimanere ma
anche come un peso per chi lo vede
arrivare oggi questa nostra esperienza
come diaspora tunisina e abbiamo scelto
di chiamarci in questo modo non più
migranti o emigranti colui che partono
che lasciano o colui che arrivano ma
quelli che si organizzano per poter
influire per poter lavorare
questo lo dobbiamo tutte quelle persone
che sono morte per darci questo potere
di parola quello che oggi mi permette di
essere qui su questo palco
diversamente da tante altre persone che
vengono dai paesi dall africa ma anche
da altre parti del mondo dove non
possono parlare perché sono governati da
colui che li fermano e non gli
permettono di usare le loro ricchezze di
crescere di costruire la libertà per me
la libertà è stata regalata regalata da
tutti quelli che in tunisia sono usciti
in piazza donne e uomini per poter
d'armi questo questa chance di essere
qui con voi ma anche soprattutto una
responsabilità per costruire il mio
paese e vorrei condividere questo questa
idea di speranza che le cose cambiano
anche se non lo vogliamo
e continuano a cambiare anche se non
siamo sulla barca del cambiamento
allora io dico questo tante persone
spesso mi dicono tu sei troppo
entusiasta sei troppo speranzosa credi
in un mondo migliore
io dico no io sono una persona realista
io ho vissuto sotto la dittatura io ho
avuto paura
io so cosa sentono tante altre persone
oggi in tanti posti nel mondo
e cosa sentivano quelli che in italia
hanno vissuto ai tempi sotto la
dittatura e so che cosa significa non
poter agire e non poter fare invece oggi
grazie a questo grandissimo cambiamento
io so cosa vuol dire poter far parte di
un cambiamento e quindi quello che io
vorrei condividere con voi e che
queste connessioni che vedete qui che
tanti tra le reti che promuovono logica
il terrore hanno capito hanno capito la
potenzialità di cui hanno capito la
potenzialità
io oggi quello che voglio dire che noi
che facciamo parte di queste reti non
sono connessioni virtuali non sono
connessioni informatiche ma sono ponti
tra persone individui e comunità e
questi ponti funzionano quindi non non
credo che sia il caso di subire il
cambiamento
io l'ho vissuto e grazie al cielo nel
mio paese rispetto ad altri paesi
la democrazia si sta instaurando si sta
costruendo il nostro dovere tutti quanti
e di proteggere questa libertà di farne
frutto e di capire il valore che ha
perché se si dimentica che c'è chi ha
sofferto o ha pagato la propria vita per
darci questa fortuna non solo di
lamentarci o di parlare ma soprattutto
di agire
abbiamo tradito la sua memoria oggi
questo sta succedendo in tunisia e io
vorrei dire che dall'africa può arrivare
un messaggio di speranza ma vorrei che
fosse anche un messaggio di speranza che
parta anche dall'europa
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]